Ahora que hemos repasado todos los elementos del VQE, vamos a
resumir lo que aprendimos y ver cómo lo ejecuta una computadora cuántica.
Empezamos con nuestro estado de referencia cuidadosamente elegido, el circuit parametrizado,
la elección inicial de parámetros y un Hamiltoniano.
Pasamos todo esto a nuestra computadora cuántica.
Antes de que el Hamiltoniano pueda ejecutarse sobre el estado ansatz,
necesitamos hacer un preprocesamiento clásico del circuit
para que el hardware cuántico pueda leerlo, en un proceso llamado transpilación.
También es importante aprovechar al máximo
la arquitectura de qubits del hardware real para obtener los mejores resultados.
Estos procesos suelen realizarse de forma automática para que no tengamos que
conocer explícitamente la conectividad de los qubits,
las fidelidades de los gates y demás.
Ahora la tarea es medir el estado resultante
y estimar el valor de expectación, que será posteriormente
optimizado por un optimizador clásico.
Esta medición se realiza rotando la base de medición
y luego combinando los resultados para obtener el valor de expectación.
Este resultado parametrizado se introduce entonces
en el optimizador clásico, que encuentra nuevos parámetros para el estado.
Luego el proceso se repite.
Un preprocesamiento clásico crea un nuevo circuit parametrizado
y aplicamos el mismo Hamiltoniano de antes.
Ten en cuenta que en todo el proceso VQE solo cambiamos los estados
a través de los parámetros, que se acercan cada vez más al estado fundamental.
Repetimos esto hasta que estamos satisfechos con el resultado.
Y eso es todo.
Mi nombre es Victoria Lipinska y este fue el curso de variational quantum eigensolver.